our guests today are the vicious
brothers colin minihan and stuart ortiz
the vicious brothers are the writing
directing collaboration between two 25
year old filmmakers who first met
through a filmmaking web form in 1999
and bonded through their shared love of
horror
and sci-fi films along with
a mutual hatred of films interesting
together they've written four feature
film scripts and collaborated on dozens
of media projects
their debut feature film grave
encounters has recently acquired
domestic distribution through tribeca
film and had its world premiere at the
2011 tribeca film festival the trailer
for the film which they produced
themselves quickly went viral on the
internet and gathered
1.5 million youtube hits in only three
months it now has close to 21 million
hits grave encounters follows lance
preston and the crew of grave encounters
a ghost hunting reality television show
shooting an episode inside the abandoned
psychiatric hospital where unexplained
phenomenon has been reported for years
in order to play out for the cameras and
audience the group voluntarily locked
themselves inside the building for the
night
and began a paranormal investigation
capturing everything on camera they
quickly quickly realized that the
building is more than just haunted it is
alive and it has no intention of ever
letting them leave please welcome to
film courage via telephone colin minihan
and stuart ortiz welcome gentlemen
hey how's it going hey we're doing great
how are you
yeah we're connected to the vicious
brothers you can connect with stu and
colin on twitter at vicious bros you can
you can also make sure to follow at
grave encounters we do love to read
tweets on the air our handle at film
courage
the hashtag for the show is hashtag
filmcourage and you can follow the
stream on tweetchat.com
all right well again thanks so much for
joining us today and we're so impressed
with your trailer and the following that
you've gained we want to just jump right
in and ask you just real quickly which
film is scarier paranormal activity or
grave encounters
you know um you know and it's you know
forgive us it's hard not to draw up
comparisons to paranormal activity you
know when you see sort of a found
footage film like this you know one
thing we want to jump into
um right off the bat
is is what is the best moment that this
film has brought to you guys you know is
it something that happened in production
is it the day the trailer went viral is
it the world premiere at tribeca you
know what is the moment um that you know
that sort of made making this film worth
all the effort that you guys have put
into it
oh man that's uh
yeah i i don't know if there was one
event
you know what is it i think from it's
great like
it's like the
nashville experience it's always
it's always really important really
awesome to see it so just doing
festivals and seeing seeing old men
curled up in their seats crying while
they're watching it because they're so
scared they can't keep your eyes on the
screen it's always very satisfying kind
of conducting
conducting the audience like that with a
scary movie and getting them involved so
definitely for me i think that the whole
like seeing the big screen or whatever
is always a lot of excitement there so
the audience reaction rather than sort
of the accolades is more
yeah absolutely it's about the audience
it's about them being you know enamored
within that
setting for that hour and a half what
they're there for interesting
you know i mean you know i hate to bring
this up i mean the film got turned you
know it's sundance season right now and
the film did get turned down by sundance
and other big name festivals but
um you know that was before you received
word from tribeca or you know afterward
you received word from tribeca and you
had your world premiere there
um what was your sort of
state of mind or mental attitude
when these you know the festivals before
tribeca kind of turned you guys away i
mean you know i mean where were you what
were you guys thinking then
and and were you thinking towards
self-distribution as an option for the
way you guys would release the film
from other festivals we were definitely
bummed out and you know it's always
discouraging because you want to try to
get into one of those top level tier uh
festivals if you can because obviously
that just helps your shot at getting the
film out there and getting you know more
visibility
to the film and helping you get you know
distribution possibly so you know we
were bummed out but we kind of we felt
like i don't even remember really
i don't even really remember what the
film was submitted to because we didn't
really handle the successful submissions
like we signed on with a foreign sales
visit pretty quickly arc light in l.a it
represents a ton of movies and takes
them to various markets and so forth
i think we went to china when we went to
toronto
yeah it might have been i don't i'm not
sure but then the
guy at tribeca tribeca is much like in
the same vein of sundance now where
they're kind of doing their own
distribution as well like obviously
there's the sundance now and then
there's tribeca film now so it's kind of
interesting to see these film festivals
buying the movies that are they're
actually you know they're using the
festival in a way to to launch their own
content as well as to premiere new stuff
so
it's important to be able to get into
kind of any of those major festivals in
order to get seen by the right people
but i don't think
not with this film we never really
talked about self-distribution i mean i
think in order for self-distribution to
be really effective you need to have
quite a big following
maybe it'll work if you're someone like
kevin smith that has like a million
twitter followers and you can kind of
cut out the middleman and go directly to
your audience it's kind of a no-brainer
in that
in that scenario you know if it's like
lewis day or something selling a comedy
show or whatever it's like he's already
got this huge following that reaching
that audience is made a lot simpler but
i think if you're you know if you're
starting fresh and you know that have
that all in doing doing that on
you know going to consume years of your
life and and once you're done making a
filmmaker you put so much of yourself
into it that you know trying to
sell it and
it's a whole other animal so i don't
think you know
it's interesting to hear you say that
because you know that when you release
the trailer online it goes viral over a
million views i mean a lot of people we
talk to don't have that kind of success
or that kind of demand of people
you know viewing their trailer and
potentially wanting to see their film
um
you know how do you react how do you
react to that side of it because there
are people that that don't want to see
this
yeah no for sure i mean youtube like
being a breakout viral thing on there is
obviously
super challenging and kind of random but
you really need to work at that sort of
thing too you know when i think like stu
and i cut the trailer ourselves before
we actually had a us distributor in
place and
i think we were just bored and we were
kind of just like you know what this
isn't happening quick enough let's just
stick it online and we'll see what
happens and and you know if some
momentum can build people will get to
notice it that way so that was really
our motivating factor
putting the trailer online it wasn't
like you know youtube doesn't have the
behind now button and you can stick
right next to the thing so it's kind of
hard to even if even if they're you know
kids are seeing it on there they're
most likely gonna
go see see if it's available on firebase
five seconds later
how did you drum up um interest in the
trailer i mean how did you
you know what did you do to kind of make
it
get so many hits or did you not do
anything you just put it out there and
it took off
we just pretty much put out the uh yeah
we we put it up on our own account and
it really wasn't getting that much
traffic but then this other guy that has
a channel on youtube that has a bunch of
horror trailers that's called hornets
who he has kind of a following he he
basically re posted onto his channel and
then that's when it blew up because he
already had uh some followers
okay yeah exactly i think that
additionally the officer was you know he
was like emailing all the major blog
sites that are independently run and we
were getting a lot of
we were getting a fair bit of press at
the time i mean like maybe three months
after it had been on the tribeca film
festival thing started happening so then
you know there's a lot of we're doing a
lot of press for that so i was able to
gain momentum there as well
okay we got on twitch film and we got on
any cool news
and uh bloody disgusting and sites like
that i think definitely drew awareness
and you guys approached them you emailed
them or did they come to you we're just
wondering how like because it's taking
that proactive well i think
it's mostly it's not like the publicist
from like the festival or or whatever it
was you know
yeah it's it's really tough because
like uh our you know when we were didn't
have a distributor signed on we had been
hitting up play disgusting pretty much
like every day just being like hey check
out a trailer would you mind like
posting this or whatever they pretty
much ignored us completely i think until
we actually had a
us distributor on board and then that
completely just changed the game and
like overnight they were you know
posting about it right right built
credibility
now you both have probably ignoring that
because we turned down their sales
they tried to buy the movie
oh i see okay
well now you both have a fascination
with the other world and we understand
colin that you almost have sort of a
mediumistic
quality to you where spirits are drawn
to you or you're perceptive enough to
pick up
well i thought we've heard it in another
interview so we're just curious how that
has taken place you're just uh you're
sensitive enough to feel other entities
in the room or they're they're drawn to
you
uh you know it's it's few and far
between when something like that does
happen but there i have been known to
experience a few hauntings in my life
that are kind of
you know i blow my mind and they make me
more attracted to the subject matter of
ghosts and making a ghost film because
it's just something i don't understand
but something that i can't explain that
you know i've encountered a few times in
my life
okay well are there stories that either
one of you can
yeah there definitely is i mean i mean
like
there's a
there's really
there's this time when i was actually in
san jose staying at this old old house
shooting a music video and um
and in the middle of the night there's
all these crazy sounds and uh i heard
like just things that you
my eyes are wide open and there's nobody
in the room with me but i can hear
someone running along the wood floor
panels right in front of me and hear a
bang on the wall and look towards the
bang and there's nobody there and
learned later that there was this whole
that it happened at the house so just
stuff like that you know you had a baby
didn't you
you're like a baby yeah right i heard i
yeah i heard a baby and i heard like
this shaking rattling sound coming up
and down the hallway and i couldn't
figure out for the life of what the hell
this was and then you know like today i
asked the uh i'm like straight up to the
owner of that i'm like this place is
completely haunted
tell me what happened
and uh turned out like this baby this a
couple owners ago there was a
a baby and the father put like a
rattling like a shaker toy that's like a
double-sided thing but he didn't notice
it when he said
that it was like broken in the middle
and
and the baby ended up getting the the
throat the thing lodged in its throat
and the dad tried to get it out but
every time he tried to reach in to get
it out he just kept pushing it further
down and down and the baby died and so
i'm hearing the remnants of this dad and
his baby in the middle of the night so
there's definitely some weird stuff in
the world
wow
so we understand that the two of you
have had cameras in your hands for most
of your lives can you tell us about the
first time
that you picked up a camera
and why this is i i don't know man we
both have i mean
i pretty much like literally
grabbed my parents old vhs camera like
when i was probably four or five and
just started
it was like such an old camera that it
literally was like tethered to the vcr
by like a cable like it wasn't really
portable so the first two years or three
years of movies i shot at all like from
one angle pretty much like in my living
room my parents living room but uh
back in the day i was just shooting like
puppet shows yeah a lot of puppet shows
i was like four years old i would search
like just shooting puppet shows and then
like
it just it just went on from there yeah
i mean it's a similar similar thing i
think i was probably like eight years
old and i discovered my mom's video
camera and
you know i was really into like action
movies and stuff at the time and playing
guns with my friends and we just
recreate different scenes from their
movies basically every day after school
and it uh
kind of never stopped doing that to a
certain extent
so there you go and when did that switch
happen for you for you guys where you
said you know what this isn't just fun
and games this isn't just a hobby
anymore like you know i want to do this
this this is kind of what i'm passionate
about this is what i love like was there
a switch
you know where that became the case
i think that there was definitely
yeah
there was a moment where
yeah i mean you know me and colin had
been friends for a while and we talked
online and we'd also met in real life a
couple times and you know we were we
kind of collaborated one time colin uh
was like the
dop on like this short film that i was
trying to make and we were kind of like
working together on stuff like that but
at some point we just kind of started
talking about the idea of just writing a
script it wasn't even let's make a movie
it was just like let's just try to write
a script so we
went up to
vancouver island where khan's mom lives
basically you know went down into a
basement and just started smoking a
bunch of weed and just like tripping out
down there listening to the sound to
movie soundtracks and we ended up
writing basically our first feature
length script and uh unfortunately it
was
probably because how just stone we were
and how crazy we were we ended up being
this thing that was just way too
ambitious to really to really do at the
time in terms of money it was just going
to be too expensive
and then so we basically kind of went
back to the drawing board and came up
with another script and again it ended
up being
ambitious
anymore
that that helped that got the budget
down a bit
but even that script again was too
ambitious and then i think we even wrote
a third one i can't remember what it was
but at some point we basically said okay
this is ridiculous we need to actually
write something that you know we can
make for like no money and then and we
had toyed a long time with the idea of
should we do a fan footage thing should
we do maybe something like along the
lines of blair witch project but we
didn't really want to do that because
it's just it's such an opposite kind of
spectrum of you know traditional
narrative filmmaking that that we love
and uh it's you know it's way more just
it looks like crap and it is supposed to
have this like kind of amateur feel to
it so we kind of had avoided it i think
for a long time but then at some point
it was just like well you know we heard
it we actually hadn't even seen
paranormal activity yet when we uh wrote
the script for grave encounters although
we'd heard of it and we'd seen like the
trailer and seen some bugs about it so
we know what the idea was but it wasn't
even out yet we literally more
influenced but i think
like blair witch project and there's a
couple of these other movies there's
like this great sound footage alien
abduction film from like the uh mid 90s
that's called the mcpherson project
where there's like this
family on thanksgiving and like they end
up getting terrorized by aliens and
stuff and uh we're kind of more just
influenced by that and obviously these
ghost hunting shows but uh that that was
definitely the moment where our
mentality really switched to just the
practical
uh reality of it of that we want to make
something but we don't have very much
money so we need to write something that
we can actually do
yeah totally like we've been trying to
get money to do one of our other scripts
and it's just like you know
not having a true understanding of just
the business of
film and
being more looked at as
especially myself looked at exclusively
as like a music video director because
that's what i've been doing for the past
you know
10 years or whatever
so i think it's it's it's important you
know to we we just
had to look at it from a different
perspective and say you know what no
one's going to help us make this but
ourselves so we should we should work
idea because we know that we can achieve
it for
you know at least you know the money
that's in our bank account and really
had to have to do just that so that's
why i think that was our motivating
factor to making a pound footage for
sure well you guys both saved up what 30
grand each isn't that what you said in
another interview yeah that's a nice
chunk of chance
we
had another investor who's been like a
lot more than that to help us finish the
film because you can get you can get so
far in production but then ultimately
when when you sign a distribution
contract and stuff you need to be able
to hand over
all the deliverables that that um
add up into the hundreds of thousands
pretty quickly so you know
by that point we were well on our way
that weren't able to get the rest of the
money any budget tips you can pass along
i mean 30 grand is a nice chunk of
change
um well i think that i think that you
know just you i think in this day and
age
there's actually a really great article
that edward burns does an interview
recently just talking about the state of
filmmaking and
and uh video on demand and stuff like
that but
but like i'll use his film as an example
because it's even better but um with his
new film newlyweds they he he basically
just did the low budget union agreement
same deal as we did for actors so you're
paying actors like a hundred bucks a day
but you're also giving them a piece of
the back end if the film ever goes on to
make money or get the distribution deal
but i mean cameras and stuff are so
cheap in this day and age you off you
can go buy a 5b and some lenses for you
know a few thousand dollars and all of a
sudden you've got yourself a camera
package that's
you know as long as it's in the right
hands is is completely applicable to
shooting a motion picture with
essentially so
um it's really just a matter of
your own personal drive and and having a
script that you know if you're not
shouting down streets doing car chases
you're you're working within the reality
that
you're presenting to the audience and
it's
keeping the scale of the production
smaller but you know keeping scale small
sometimes is a good thing so
sometimes re-looking at things and being
like you know how can we approach this
from
from a cheaper perspective ultimately it
forces you to become more creative so i
think you know there's a lot of a lot of
independent films being made for for
similar kind of prices and they all kind
of end up around a hundred grand by the
end of it even if
you know penny pinching and i think
casting through or whatever
um it's
just delivering a movie is really
successful i think that you can't really
get away from from spending that kind of
money but you can definitely shoot
production really cheaply with with the
technology that's out there
and just using natural light you know
well i want to go back to when you guys
did meet on this filmmaking forum online
i mean how did you know that you could
trust one another it's hard in this day
and age you meet people online and they
seem cool and then you meet them in
person and it's just you see they have
an agenda so how did you know over the
years that okay
i can trust this person and we can work
together
it pretty much just started because i
think
you know we were we were the only people
that we had met on this filmmaking forum
that i guess were kind of the same age
but really just that we were really
genuinely impressed by the other
person's work like there's a lot of
people on it was this one it was like
basically be there i think it was the
original filmmaking form that existed on
the internet it was this forum called
like a story and it vanished i don't
know
1999 or 2000 or something like that it's
long long gone
but that's that's where he met and uh
yeah i think it's just like we were just
impressed by what we were doing so there
was there was a mutual respect and then
when we were always talking online too
just chatting and even
yeah we just just kind of clicked and
then
when we we finally met in real life a
couple years later it was just like
you know we just clicked i think you
know pretty instantly it was right yeah
i get this guy hear the same language
each other before we even met too though
right like 30 years of just like talking
on instant messenger and like you know i
remember my mom walking by and i was
like talking to some pervert online or
whatever
that's awesome
you know like i i think after a certain
while we just we realized that we were
kind of thinking on a very similar
wavelength when we talked about the
movies that we like and movies that we
were interested in making and just stuff
like that and then finally meeting in
person i think after we met in person it
was like you know another
three years or whatever until we decided
to actually do something cool together
um so definitely a slow burn
right right before we before we even met
colin had been working on this film that
he was making this this thing called
choice and uh we would stay up pretty
much all night and he would send me
little scenes and be like what do you
think and i'd be like you should make
this a little bit longer make this shot
10 frames longer do this do that or
whatever
just going back and forth and then there
was a point where calm proposed the idea
of and we hadn't met yet in real life
but that we could meet on screen
so i had actually uh like painted a blue
screen wall like in uh in one of the
rooms in my houses my dad didn't even
know i was gonna do that i just he just
came home one day and discovered that i
painted an entire wall blue and he was
not too scared but he went along with it
but anyway with a you know a blue screen
you can basically shoot a shot of
whatever on the blue screen then you can
composite that into another shot so
colin filmed a shot of him walking just
walking by the camera
yeah and then i filmed a shot of me on
the blue screen walking by the camera
and kind of acting like he had knocked
into me or whatever like looking at him
and then i sent him the file and then he
composited that in and then that's how
the that's basically how we first met
was on screen so there you go oh very
cool
well i understand that you both have a
mutual hatred of film school did either
of you attend film school did you have a
bad experience there what's your
argument
against film schools
yeah we both went to film school i think
i think that just was a little a sound
bite that we used in the bio just to
sound crazy hey film school i went to a
an art school for one year
i didn't like it at all but i mean to be
fair
super super
very experimental very liberal very
art-minded film program and i mean like
the on the extreme side of the spectrum
i mean they would show us like films
where it would be like literally 20
minutes of like white which is like a
scratching sound effect literally and
that would be like someone's film and
then people would talk about it really
seriously afterwards and it was only
there for a few months before i was just
looking around and being like man i do
not belong in here i want to be making
like you know terminator 2 or something
like that and then so i just kind of
basically stopped going to class and
started working on making this other
film this kind of action adventure film
with some other guy that was going there
and uh i remember i would show parts
parts of it in class and all the
students just were like man this is just
hollywood just hollywood
like this is so like derivative and
shitty and stuff like that and like i
just had no idea
huh
there was some dope stuff you were doing
too it's so this i think it's really
discouraging it can be really
discouraging when you're put in an
environment like that where you know
your kind of cast is now a matter
because what you're doing is a lot more
mainstream than the other people from my
film school
i mean my perspective is like i just
remember the first day of class and like
basically schooling the editing teacher
like he was like trying to teach us
something
something like white transition
thing like ocean's 11 or something like
that and he was trying to tell us how it
was done and i had to make him go frame
by frame and
correct him as to how it was done
because he wasn't teaching it right so
um
and he you know he was like oh crap i
wasn't and that was like the first day
of school so i it was just i'd been
working on my own stuff so much and
taught myself just you know everything
that i knew at the time so
going into the program and and you know
the faculty
wasn't very supportive and
dean was a total
uh it just it was it's just a downer
because you're there and you're like
they're teaching kids how to like hit
the red button on a camera and what
exposure is and like just like wasting
money on all this that i've already
taught myself so i think if you've
already picked up a camera a much better
investment it's
and the other thing is kids don't finish
anything once they're out of film school
like they have like this they train you
so much through the education system
that it's important to get good grades
and
kind of carry that forward into
post-secondary and and film school
obviously so you get all these kids that
are just changing things to try and
achieve a letter grade but then just
graduate the program they think that you
know a certificate is going to be worth
something
it's obviously not but it's the sham of
film school funeral is that they
convince these kids that don't know
anything about filmmaking or anything
about the industry that they're going to
get jobs with a piece of piece of paper
and i'd see it all the time and i knew
right away like i knew when i went there
that it was not how it worked
but i went there anyways just because i
grew up in such a small town and i
needed to get the hell away from it to
make cities so
well the one positive thing was just
being around
being around people that were
they were uh into film and that was kind
of the first time in my life other than
knowing stu that was surrounded by other
people that wanted to make film even if
they didn't do anything and they're just
like that was a positive experience for
me but but just being there and you know
they never like going back to what i'm
saying how they're working for a letter
grade it's really disappointing because
you see like
50 kids graduate and you know two of
them end up working in the film industry
and that's them end up working
mcdonald's or something like that
because they really never knew what they
wanted to do in first place so they
never really had that for sure
i think film school is is a the only use
it has is if you just have no
technical training whatsoever and how to
do anything with film how to shoot a
scene how to light stuff etcetera and
film school films good for them i can
open up google
please yes man you pay 40 grand but i
mean the reality of the industry is it's
so much more than that i mean you know
there's a whole business side that they
never talk about and i really think the
honestly the only way that you can
really learn that stuff is just to do it
and to experience it you know
do you think having that degree almost
hinders you in some way uh from taking
risks that i think you kind of show it i
think
oh maybe from taking risks yeah because
they have that piece of paper and
they're like hey you know what i put in
all this time and this money and i have
to get this quote-unquote sort of real
film job whereas the more the the diy
sort of rebels go out and do it
themselves because they have less
writing on the fact that they
they didn't have all that i
yeah maybe i mean i think i think just
for most for most kids you know they're
probably perfectly happy getting a
operating at the local news station for
the next 10 years well film school's
good for
that kind of thing but i mean i you know
i don't i'm giving a biased example i
can only speak for the film school that
i was at i don't know maybe ucla film
school or whatever is amazing and new
york film academy is awesome i don't
know haven't been there so you know from
our perspective i think that
that it's a bit of a joke so and i
definitely agree that it
it it probably makes kids not want to
take those risks and they don't really
encourage those risks at least none of
the teachers that i had were you know
showing us rebel without a crew and
telling us to just film school go
make a movie you know they weren't
saying that they're selling the idea
that you need this certificate you need
to show up and pay your tuition fees
sell your blood for medical tests you
know we are i love getting into the film
school debate here
we are on the line with the vicious
brothers stuart ortiz and colin minihan
let's jump back into grave encounters
and really curious how you guys
were able to get the psychiatric
hospital
as the primary location for the film do
you want to take this one
oh well yeah it's just
it's a location uh that we knew about
it's a
you know it's a well-known filming
location here in vancouver that has been
shot at a million times for a million
different things x-files we shot a bunch
of episodes there and it's like i think
it's one of the most heavily filmed at
locations in canada yeah so we knew
about the location
control there
yeah comment shot like a papa roach
music video there and like a bunch of
other videos so one i mean it was just
like when we came up with the idea for
the film
we knew right away that we were gonna
shoot it there that would be the place
to do it and we wrote the script based
around the location and what what we
knew was there
so that's great you know yeah we
definitely we
wrote for the most production value just
knowing the location in and out like the
there's a scene in the in the film where
they are hiding in this like room with
all these decrepit bathtubs that are
just strewn out all over the place and
it looks like it's probably our designs
but it's not we wrote the scenes because
we knew those bathtubs were in there
and it was an amazing looking spot so
you know it's such a great location as
well you know and you're mentioning you
know the
the you know building the script around
you know what you knew you had you know
how how detailed what was the script you
know that you wrote for the grave
encounters you know because it is a
found footage film
and
with a film like this you want to make
it seem authentic so you know
you know i would believe that you'd want
to leave room to have the actors be free
and have improv
you know so can you talk about um you
know how detailed was the script how far
did you take that and how much room was
there for for improv
we wrote a full pretty much 80 page
script
because you know there's a couple of
different approaches i think you can
have to a found footage film like i know
that on blair witch project i don't
think they had like i don't think they
literally had a shooting script at all i
think they had kind of a rough outline
of kind of scenes and what was going to
happen but just in a real rough way and
i mean those actors were literally out
in the woods by themselves filming
everything themselves and i think from
what i understand is that the directors
would leave them like little packages in
areas because they had a gps that would
explain plot points like
new things that were going to happen but
then sometimes they would just outright
surprise them and in the middle of
the night so it was very very just you
know they were catching everything super
candidly and then on the opposite end of
the spectrum you know you can have a
film like uh what's an example something
like uh quarantine which which is the
american remake of wreck which is you
know i'm assuming it's just is
completely scripted every single line is
like is scripted
and uh i think you know we we kind of
wanted to land somewhere in the middle
we knew that we needed to write a full
script because you know we were paying x
amount of dollars for the location per
day so we couldn't just be kind of
goofing off and not knowing what we were
doing so we knew we needed to have you
know a full script that we could go off
as a framework basically but at the same
time we definitely went in there being
really open to doing you know improv how
many cameras did you use
a lot
the actors were rolling as well because
i mean
you were trying to create the you know
the reality television ghost hunting
aesthetic that everyone's really
familiar with and it very much is a
parody of those shows if you know if
there's anything that's seen those
both shows and
is into them it's basically you know a
group of ghost hunters
and it we really wanted it to just look
and feel like that so cameras are super
cheap for that kind of thing because
you're talking about shooting on like an
hdv night vision camera for a lot of a
lot of the scenes and
and um i think ultimately we probably
had like
maybe like eight cameras on set and
sometimes all of them were rolling oh
wow jeez it's a lot of a lot of cameras
to be looking at but the primary camera
uh either stu or i was operating with an
actor behind us and we basically just
re-run the scene um from from the other
angles as well
with uh with the actor fake filming or
he was real filming but you know
not we didn't have really time to put
them through a proper crash course so
their cinematography was a bit jank
so we'd have to go in there and make
sure that we got the stuff that we knew
we needed but um
but yeah even going back to the script i
think that when we wrote the script it
was it was really uh
we left a lot of the scenes wide open
improv and we just knew
point a b c and where it needed to go
and let the actors work out the rest and
it was interesting because
actors are obviously give them that much
freedom and they're just gonna run wild
with it but we're able to control a lot
of that because it's really a film built
around the jump cut and you could use a
portion of take
five and a portion of take one and
unfortunately take three
any good moment from any of these takes
and essentially
make it feel like it was part of a
wonder really but it just feels edited
for time because it's it's it's you know
the edits are supposed to be kind of
jarring and in that jump cut fashion
you're able to get away with a lot of
bad improv and kind of circumventing
your way through it and getting around
it
well you know and you mentioned eight
cameras i mean how much footage did you
guys end up with overall and and how
long did the edit take i mean how many
hours were you putting in sort of each
day
um in post on the edit
i think we must have literally had like
70 hours or something a footage it was
completely ridiculous and some of the
worst ratio in the history yeah
there would be part like times where the
actors would you know forget that their
camera was running and go to like for
lunch so we'd be looking at a tape and
it'd literally be like 45 minutes of it
just sitting like against a wall or
something so that was it was a huge a
huge job because we pretty much had to
just sit there and like watch almost
every you know every second of it just
to try to pull any moment that we could
there was any good but that definitely
made it take a lot longer because like a
lot of those active cameras weren't even
slated properly too so you're trying to
sync them to sound as well and you're
just like oh
they're trying to figure out what the
hell the scene is
they're like what is this scene what the
hell what the hell was this scene what
were we shooting here what is this
what is your footage
you know so
how long were you guys spending in post
i mean how long was each day i mean were
you guys putting in 12 hour days in the
edit bay or
ended the movie
yeah like when we pretty much did the
movie like
like i literally just moved kind of
basically to canada and just slept on
colin's couch in his uh apartment for
i don't know a year and a half or
whatever it was until we got the movie
done so we were basically living
together and
just we had set up
the computer in the middle of his living
room and we're just at it day in and day
out constantly now i know how long was
it that we were imposing all right we
cut i think we cut initially probably
for like you know we had a rough cut but
ran like two and a half hours like two
weeks after shooting the movie basically
and then we just kept fine-tuning and
fine-tuning it and i think probably
after like a month or so we we took some
time away from it and
you know um
i think you need to if you're
involved with the film for that long you
kind of need to be able to back away
from it and come back to with a fresh
perspective months of
editing
actors footage that you could barely
tell what's going on
and just trying to
it's there's
like with these sounds movies you're
trying to you're really trying to sell
realism and you said it earlier how
you're trying to create that signature
feel so that's why we we approached it
like that and we we knew that from you
know our primary
cameras that there'd be great stuff but
if you were to hold on them for too long
it just starts to feel too cinematic so
we
it was important that we we allowed our
actors to basically film whatever the
hell they wanted to so that even if it
was something crappy that you would
usually cut out of a picture
it could you could shift in and you
could help sell the realism of the the
situation and just with the raw um
camera operating skills basically
so after post what did you do to restore
your backs
our backs were all messed up because we
were literally were we didn't even set
up a desk i think because we were too
excited we just wanted to start cutting
so we were like okay we'll just
temporarily use this coffee table as the
place and then we'll get a real desk in
here in a little bit and then the real
desk never came so it's just a coffee
table the entire time i see a couch and
a coffee table
and a good chiropractor
killing pissing my neighbors off too
probably like because i had a rough
sound mix as well and they're like you
know playing demon rowell sounds at full
volume at like three in the morning like
on a loop trying to like
what i'm wondering is with a
collaboration like the two of you have
you know how do you know when one person
should sort of steer the ship and then
the other should take a back seat do you
ever switch roles um is there a division
of labor does one of you tire of the
project and the other one sort of carry
the torch and then you pass it back and
forth
uh you know i mean
yeah i guess we're still figuring out it
seems i don't know people ask about the
collaboration it's kind of just like it
just sort of works i don't know how else
to explain it i mean i think part of it
is the fact that we co-write together
and that's a that's a real collaborative
intense process because you know
literally sometimes we'll write a script
and we'll be going back and forth over
just like dialogue over like a few like
lines of dialogue back and forth so
we're very much you know
one by the time the script is done it's
very like collaborative and it's both of
our visions and then you know we discuss
all everything all the shops how we want
to do it and it's you know we just we
trust each other and respect each other
so much at this point i think initially
when we started like working on script
one there was a lot more haggling and
fighting and stuff like that but at this
point it's just kind of like
you know the catchphrase we always use
is if someone has another idea that what
the other doesn't agree with it's just
like all right well sell me on it then
sell me on the idea how is the idea
better and then you give the other
person a chance and they can break it
down and you go yeah okay you're right
my idea does suck your ideas better or
nah it doesn't really work you know and
we always end up seeing eye to eye so
yeah and i think as far as actually
being on set when
time is of the essence and you can't
you might not have time to shoot
everything two different ways if you're
eye to eye it's important during
pre-production to
plan and do your homework because that's
what filmmaking is filmmaking is your
homework before you're on set like if if
you don't have that you're screwed
basically you know so
it's like a matter of really being
inside one another's head and we're both
very
vocal on set it isn't like one of us
hides behind the monitor and the other
directs the movie it's like we're
constantly whispering in one another's
ears about everything basically every
decision being is a joint decision and
we're constantly
being forced to sell one another on why
this approach works why this approach
works why this approach works and seeing
eye to eye and it can be it can be um i
think it can become a tiring process if
you don't if you don't work closely
enough
before you're on set
shooting so you need to be able to like
have the same vision going into it for
sure um
thank you for touching on that you know
and we want to touch on we want to come
back to this tribeca distribution deal
um because
our understanding is you do have a deal
with with tribeca film so you know where
you guys offered the deal before the
festival and and why did you decide to
go with with this offer
i don't remember was it before
after the festival i can't remember uh i
think i think we thought we were
negotiating it all the way up to it
probably i don't i don't know but um
i think like you know
if you think and look at their slate
this year i mean they're getting a lot
of really cool movies they've got tony
case attachment coming out
they're kind of like you know there's a
lot of these distribution companies that
that have really changed their models
just their distribution model because
the kind of the art house theater's sort
of in a way dying so
i think they're they're resorting to
a new strategy of releasing movies and
it's it's called day and date where you
know they'll put it out a limited
theatrical run and they'll they'll do
video on demand simultaneously
and it kind of eliminates that window
system that hollywood loves
you know there's like ifc is doing a lot
of day and date now and obviously
magnolia and magnet
run i think
pretty much all of magnet stuff is day
and date whether it's outdated they
might even be out on itunes on like a
premium rental before it's available on
other formats so there really is a lot
of experimenting going on with the way
that films are released and
and vod is great because it's growing so
much right now i think i think like the
whole piracy issue is like another thing
you can easily stem this conversation
but if you make the content super
convenient for the consumers which is
what tribeca and italy companies are
trying to achieve then people are less
like say say there's a movie that's in
theater and i may not want to see it
until it's on video because i just don't
want to go to the theater and see it
well if it's a tribeca movie or an ifc
thing or a magnet thing i didn't have
that choice that that choice isn't
my office isn't torrented and watched
the cam version of it because it's only
available in theater the fact is that i
can rent it right away on my on my uh
video on demand via whatever format
you're into comcast or something like
that so i think that these these newer
companies are pretty smart by reading
the same date thing but at the same time
obviously
i love the theatrical experience and i
hope that that doesn't hurt that
revenue stream but it definitely does
make films available to a wider audience
faster and that's a good thing for a
filmmaker because you know people's
televisions are awesome these days and
the experience that i get sitting in my
place watching a movie is arguably
almost as good as the experience i get
most of the time in the theater just
because you know it's a very youth
oriented crowd and there's a lot of like
bright text message screens going off or
whatever but people kicking your chair
yeah sure kicking the chair throwing
drinks on you right and it's just you
know it's obviously not more expensive
to go out and
especially if you're like older and
you've got a family and you need to hire
a babysitter or something like that to
leave the house like you really want to
do that
and to go see a romantic comedy that
is out you know you're probably more
likely to want to rent it on your tv so
i think that the game date strategy that
tribeca has is pretty indeed
yeah and just as we wrap up here we have
like one minute left but we just wanted
to find out you know do you feel
pressure to exceed the success that
you've had with grave encounters i mean
most the people that we speak with they
come nowhere close to what you guys have
achieved and it's really amazing but i'm
sure that that's also there's also
another side to achieving all of that
because then there's that pressure to
keep up with the the same
momentum that grave encounters had
yeah i mean
yeah we feel pressure and we are you
know we're working on it right now to
try to we want to go 10 times bigger and
better with the next home absolutely
colin final words from you
yeah i mean if you're not putting
pressure on yourself and you're just
complacent then life is kind of boring i
think stu and i we stack just an
unbelievable amount of pressure on
ourselves to
to be working on stuff and to trying to
take it to the next level to the point
that it's a joke and that we got each
other completely insane doing that so
i think even though you know it's a
negative thing to
get so crazy about it but at the same
time it's super positive because our
drive is just through the roof
great stuff
we've been speaking with the filmmaking
duo the vicious brothers colin minihan
and stuart ortiz for more on the vicious
brothers please visit
theviciousbrothers.com
viciousbros and gravencounters on
twitter
graveencountersthriller.com
facebook.comgravencounters and on imdb
yeah and thanks so much colin and stu
for joining us today looking forward to
hearing about those uh next projects and
uh absolutely it goes with it yeah it's
been a joy sitting back and listening to
you guys you know just listening to some
young folks who really have a handle on
their work
um and really have a handle on the
business thank you guys for
sharing your experiences with us thanks
a lot yeah absolutely thank you
we look forward to being here with you
next sunday um and we will have
one of the uh films from the film
courage 2011 must-see list if you want
to be in this industry you have to see
the film my big break we can't tell
enough people about it it's great it's
by director tony ziera and also actor
chad lindbergh will be with us to talk
about the film it was made years ago
under a different name and then it was
brought back after hollywood did not
want people to see it it's a documentary
that captures celebrity in the making
and the unsettling effects of fame on
five friends who share a house in
hollywood
yeah those five friends were wes bentley
brad rowe greg fossett tony zera and um
tony zero is going to call into the show
and chad chandler is going to be here in
studio for more information on my big
break please visit
mybigbreakmovie.com this is one we've
been talking about forever we're sure we
can't wait very excited can't wait yeah
and until next sunday have a great week